Salut Romain ! Ah tiens y'a quoi dans ta gourde?
-C'est du vin.
Du vin ? A dix heures du mat' donc ?
Tu regardes jamais la télé ou quoi ? Y'a un ministre qu'a dit que le vin c'est pas vraiment de l'alcool
Et donc sur ta chemise là c'est pas vraiment du vomi non plus
Y'a pas longtemps le ministre de l'agriculture Didier Guillaume a dit ce truc "Je crois pas que le vin soit un alcool comme les autres
L 'addiction à l'alcool est dramatique et notamment dans la jeunesse avec le bing-drinking c'est assez dramatique mais je n'ai jamais vu
à ma connaissance
malheureusement peut-être un jeune qui sort de boîte de nuit
et qui est saoul parce qu'il a bu du Côte du Rhône, du crozes-hermitage "
Alors j'aime pas dire du mal des ministres
mais là c'est complètement con.
L 'addiction à l'alcool c'est pas se bourrer la gueule en boîte et être alcoolique
ça a rien à voir avec le genre d'alcool qu'on boit.
A vrai dire c'est pas une histoire de qualité et c'est pas non plus juste
une histoire de quantité
on va voir les choses dans l'ordre
L'alcool deja c'est quoi ? au sens strict l'alcool c'est un liquide qu'on obtient en distillant des jus sucrés fermentés et qui contient
essentiellement une substance qu'on appelle
l'éthanol ou alcool éthylique.
Dans le langage courant l'alcool c'est devenu toutes les boissons qui contiennent de l'éthanol
y compris le vin du coup hein
désole Didier
"Malheureusement peut-être "
Alors la particularité de ce brave éthanol c'est qu'il a
plusieurs particularités. D'abord il est psychotrope c'est à dire qui modifie le psychisme
l'état mental si vous voulez. Ensuite il est très addictif c'est à dire qu'on en devient très facilement dépendant aussi bien physiquement que psychologiquement
ce qui en fait une drogue
faut pas avoir peur des mots.
Il est aussi toxique pour le système nerveux le coeur les vaisseaux le foie l'estomac etc..
Il provoque des maladies comme des cancers
l'ulcère, la cirrhose, la pancréatite, les hémorragies digestives
et j'en passe et des encore moins glamour. Et en plus d'être toxique physiquement il est aussi toxique socialement
l'alcool ça détruit pas seulement la santé physique et mentale de la personne qu'on boit ça détruit aussi sa vie professionnelle,
sa vie de famille ça détruit sa vie quoi
Celle de ses proches aussi tant qu'à faire
Enfin bon quand je dis "l'alcool fait ça" on se comprend on parle de consommation
problématique d'alcool et c'est là que ça se complique un peu
alors si on fait un test si je vous demande "C'est quoi pour vous être alcoolique?"
bah il y aura surem...  ne répondez pas je ne vous entends pas
vous allez sûrement me donner un certain nombre de réponses qui sont pas complètement fausses mais qui vont sans doute être un petit peu caricaturales.
"Tu n'est vraiment pas très sympa "
Mais ne le prenez pas mal c'est pas contre vous c'est la représentation collective de l'alcoolisme qui est faussée
c'est culturel c'est normal c'est tout le monde. Le problème c'est que cette vision caricaturale de l'alcoolique, qui est quelqu'un de
complètement bourré du matin au soir,
elle a tendance à nous rassurer un petit peu trop sur notre propre consommation d'alcool. Moi je ne suis pas bouré du matin au soir donc
j'ai pas de problème d'alcool.
Pardon mais c'est pas si simple.
A partir du moment où vous buvez de l'alcool
potentiellement les problèmes commencent dans la mesure où
boire de l'alcool ça représente un risque pour la santé.
le risque peut être faible ou élevé
ou modéré mais il y en a toujours.
ça peut aller de se casser la gueule et se blesser ou avoir rapport sexuel non protégé
parce qu'on a bu et ça ça peut arriver dès la première fois qu'on boit.
Jusqu'à choper un cancer la plus on boit plus on boit souvent et plus on boit longtemps
plus on a de risques ça arrive.
En passant par tout un tas de problèmes de santé,
d'accidents de la route, de mauvais choix qui ont des sales conséquences etc
et puis ça peut aussi être
devenir dépendant à l'alcool
et ça c'est une maladie.
Une maladie qui a un côté psychologique et un côté physique
physiologique.
Parce qu'il ya plein de phénomènes neurobiologiques qui entrent en jeu et qu impliquent des substances comme la dopamine
le neurotransmetteur du plaisir la sérotonine le neurotransmetteur du bonheur les endorphines etc
mais aussi des modifications au niveau du cerveau. On va pas rentrer dans le détail c'est pas le sujet aujourd'hui
mais retenez que c'est une vraie maladie
une maladie dont la principale caractéristique est la possibilité de s'empêcher de boire de l'alcool
Mais attention, c'est pas une maladie qui arrive comme ça d'un coup
genre tu te couches "ça va", tu te réveilles bam "Je suis alcoolique".  Non c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
ça s'installe progressivement
insidieusement sans qu'on s'en rende compte
c'est aussi pour ça que c'est compliqué a repérer parce que déjà la plupart du temps on ne sait pas trop ce que c'est
mais en plus on n'a pas trop envie de savoir
et ça s'installe sans faire de bruit.
Bon mais alors comment on sait que quelqu'un est dépendant à l'alcool ? Et bah c'est difficile
parce que si on lui demande "Est ce que tu es capable de t'arrêter de boire?"
la plupart du temps la réponse va être "Oui il ya pas de problème j'arrête quand je veux"
Bon pendant un moment on disait "si tu bois au moins trois verres par jour
tous les jours : t'es alcoolique.
et puis après on s'est rendu compte que c'était pas aussi simple que ça
retenez quand même qu'il ya une notion de fréquence est une notion de quantité en gros
tout le monde et pas complètement d'accord mais si sur une semaine vous buvez en moyenne
plus de 3 verres par jour si vous êtes un homme et plus de 2 si vous êtes une femme
considérez que votre consommation est problématique. Ah oui et quand on parle de verre, on parle de verre standard
c'est à dire les doses qui sont servies dans les bars pas les doses de pirate que vous vous servez à la maison
Dans un bar quel que soit l'alcool que vous buvez vous avez la même quantité d'éthanol dans votre verre
parce qu'il y en a autant dans un demi c'est à dire dans 25 centilitres de bière que dans 10 centilitres de vin que dans
trois centilitres de whisky. Du coup notez bien qu'on peut être dépendant à l'alcool sans jamais être bourré
parce que trois verres étalés sur une journée... Concernant la quantité ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
l'organisme s'habitue à l'alcool donc il faut avoir des quantités de plus en plus importantes pour arriver aux mêmes effets
c'est ce qu'on appelle le phénomène de tolérance. Mais comme c'est pas juste une question de quantité et de fréquence voilà
dix trucs qui doivent allumer une petite lumière rouge dans notre cerveau au sujet de votre consommation d'alcool
Vous buvez tous les jours
Vous buvez par réflexe sans vraiment y réfléchir
Vous buvez seul, pas toujours mais parfois vous buvez seul
Vous êtes toujours en train de rechercher une
occasion ou un prétexte pour boire un coup
Vous buvez pour vous sentir mieux ou pour décompresser
Vous commencez à boire de plus en plus tôt dans la journée
Vous assumez mal de boire voir vous vous cachez.
ça vous arrive régulièrement de
perdre le contrôle et de boire plus que vous aviez prévu
Vous avez régulièrement des problèmes parce que vous avez trop bu
ce soit un black-out, une gueule de bois, une blessure, une impossibilité à faire
ce que vous aviez prévu de faire le jour même ou le lendemain
et malgré tout ça vous restez rarement une semaine sans boire
Alors pas besoin d'avoir tous ces signes mais si vous en avez juste un ou deux
commencez à vous poser des questions
et si vous en avez plus
prennez les choses en main. Oui parce que là on a beaucoup parlé de dépendance mais comme on l'a dit au début il ya d'autres types
de consommation d'alcool qui sont aussi problématiques pour plein de raisons et notamment parce que ça peut rendre malade ou évoluer vers la dépendance justement
alors parmi ces consommations problématiques il ya l'alcoolisation massive
régulière "avec le binge drinking " ect..
Bon mais qu'est ce qu'on fait si on se rend compte qu'on a un problème avec l'alcool
eh ben on se fait aider
par des professionnels et ça pour plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que la dépendance c'est un problème complexe avec des implications physiques psychologiques
et sociales et que ça fait beaucoup à gérer tout seul
ensuite parce que en plus d'essayer de se débarrasser d'un truc autour duquel notre vie tourne plus ou moins
c'est bien de comprendre pourquoi on en est arrivé là
pour essayer de régler le problème et d'éviter que ça recommence et enfin et peut-être même surtout parce que se sevrer tout seul de l'alcool
ça peut être dangereux
voir très dangereux. Un seuvrage mal géré ça peut dégénérer en delirium tremens
ce qui contrairement à ce qu'on pense ne consiste pas juste avoir des éléphants roses
c'est vrai que ça implique des hallucinations en l'occurrence on est plus sur des insectes
Le delirium tremens est un syndrome neurologique qui est causé par le manque d'alcool et qui donne : des sueurs, une agitation
des tremblements, une incohérence et donc des hallucinations
parce-que c'est nôtre projet!
Mais aussi une déshydratation et une accélération du rythme cardiaque
et ça peut être
mortel
alors ça arrive pas à tout le monde et il ya des signes qui permettent de prendre les choses en main avant d'en arriver là
mais le mieux c'est quand même d'emblée de se faire suivre. Avant de se quitter
j'ai bien conscience que j'ai pas répondu à la question que je pose dans le titre de la vidéo
j'avoue le but c'était pas de vous donner la réponse
c'était de vous amener à vous poser la question parce que ça a l'air de rien mais c'est
super important et surtout parce que la seule personne qui est vraiment capable de répondre
c'est vous alors bon comme maintenant vous vous posez la question
et que c'est un petit peu à cause de moi. Et qu'en vrai vous pouvez pas y répondre comme ça tout seul
je vous mets dans la description de la vidéo un lien vers un test qui va vous permettre d'évaluer votre consommation d'alcool faites moi plaisir
faites le et si les résultats sont pas clair clair
parlez-en à votre médecin ou appelez alcoolinfoservice par exemple.
Voilà DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos
d'ici là prenez soin de vous et prenez soin des autres mettez vous bien et surtout
portez-vous bien!